WITH YOU ON "HOCKEY NIGHT IN
CANADA."
SATURDAY NIGHT, FOURTH AND FINAL
MATCHUP BETWEEN THE F FO LINDHO.
HE LEFT IT THERE FOR TKACHUK,
MOVING UP AND
DEMKO'S GOT JUST ENOUGH.
AND THERE'S 40 ON THE SEASON
WHAT A DANDY UP OVER
AND JUST LIKE THAT, TWO QUICK
GOALS IN A QUICK 2-NOTHING ZONE
CANUCKS
CONOR GARLAND TWISTING AWAY FROM
HAN
ILLNESS GOING THROUGH THE TEAM,
JUST ADD TO THE ADVERSITYK, FEES
TO RIFLE THE PUCK INTO TH WHAT
LEWIS, CAREFULLY THE FLAMES
INTO THE BOARDS. OUT
A BIT SLOW TO GET UP.
THE FLAMES KEEP IT IN.
GUDBRANSON'S SHOT
CONOR GARLAND!
IT'S 2-2 IN THEY, OH MY.
>> Greg: AND HE KNOCKS IT RIGHT
OUT OF THE GOAL!
[ Horn ]
AND THE FLAMESS PLAY
JUST GOES REVERSES.
HUGHES SHOOTS, VLADAR THE SAVE,.
GARLAND TO J.T. MILLER.
BACK TO HUGHES.TWO-ON-ONE, DUBE
BACKHANDS, HE SCORES!
HURRY, AND HE THROWS IT THE GOA
LINE INTO THE NET!
[ Horn ]
DEMKO'S LE FRONT OF
PETTERSSON NOW.
SIX ATTA
WITH 2:25 TO GO, IT'SDOWN, AND
TIMEOUT AS THE CONTROL.
GAUDREAU SHOOTS, SCORES!